you're an animal lover right you love
your dog I didn't you do him do you have
a skeleton of your dog I didn't I had a
relationship with my dog that was so
precious I rescued him in Morocco in the
desert you shooting a movie you see I
see this trophy in the desert eating
camel dung out of a box because they
were clearing this set and I'm like I
just I was like I picked him up I was
like let's get this thing cleaned up
let's get him tied it up and went took
him to the vet and he gets cleaned up
and and I'm like the last thing I need
in the middle of the biggest like I was
the first time I was a lead role on a
like a Ridley Scott movie is a puppy
like keeping me up at night right it's
very difficult a puppy it's like it's
like I've created it was this incredible
bond he came with me everywhere he was
literally on set on the boat on pirates
he would sit under my chair while we
were like on on the ocean like never
made a peep he wasn't interested in
people he was a good boy he was a good
boy yeah he just was a wonderful animal
and so I'll tell you one thing for your
listeners who were dog animal lovers if
you have a dog or animal or pet that you
love get the blood work like we get
blood work done get their blood work at
it when they reach a certain age start
getting their blood strong take make
sure you you can read that get take get
a homeopathic vet if you can get one or
somebody who can administer something
that isn't necessarily like the
pharmaceutical thing because if I had
given my dog milk thistle right no yeah
that's a which you can buy
over-the-counter in his food it would
have helped with his liver and he would
have he'd probably still be in what
happened to him he just had a liver
failure and and it's because his diet
could have been correct perhaps it was
his diet perhaps it was it was you know
listen he was also a wild dog from
Morocco so right he was his dog was like
you know so I mean he was but he was how
old was he when he died
twelve and a half okay hardest I never
cry so hard in all my life
like I just couldn't stand the idea that
he was just not gonna be around anymore
and so I called this company and they
said before he passes take him to the
vet they'll freeze him and then they'll
send him to us and we will do a process
where they strip you know everything
from the body and what's left is the the
is his is his skeleton right yeah they
asked me if I wanted to keep the penis
what do you think I said I think you
look quite right so I have it on the
side he's in his favorite pose for me
which is when walkways running and and
and he's and he's hanging and it's crazy
cuz I have this window box in my house
it's like a window box where you would
sit and instead of sitting he's there
and he looks like he's running outside
and it's man it just mate when I see it
I smile and I think it makes you happy
makes it make you sad no no it makes me
it makes me happy that he's somehow you
know there's he's you know I don't know
part of your scene he's just and it
looks beautiful he was so beautiful this
dog he was a big long legs and it's
beautiful he looks like a piece of all
honestly it looks like one of those you
know how people get skulls and the cover
of Madonna right any other different
crazy things he looks like a beautiful
piece of